[Music]
you have been married for 11 years a lot
of people watching right now preparing
for Valentine's Day tomorrow they want
to know how do you keep the relationship
fresh what's the secret well I
personally like to keep a pair of heels
right by bit the bed
Oh case there's some freaky moment that
goes on I mean now we watch a lot of TV
at night and then when we want to calm
down relax I might whip on the hills
heals your tongue a shoes shoes you have
shoes by the side of your bed yeah like
shoes you dish you free I'm a shoe freak
Oh your age I get you you have a shoe
fetish I mean I wouldn't necessarily
fetish I mean I can't do it without her
they got she has to have them on if I
had a fetish all that need was the shoe
I wasn't no I wasn't implying or enjoys
implying ice that you're sneaking into
shoe stores across the country without
yo what happens you got a cans here man
and figure out what they want you I
figure out what your man a lot guys like
lingerie he doesn't like lingerie he
likes shoes okay I have a para city
might give you guys in the in the math
right didn't learn algebra oh you know
figure half I saw you so I thought you
said math for a second well if you want
math learn algebra
whatever whatever they whatever turns
that particular person on yes
figure out what pushes their buttons and
it'll help yes that's a good idea you
keep something you it all depends on
what you're into what are you into since
you're all into my business what yes I
like my wife two dresses Teddy Roosevelt
Oh
[Applause]
thanks great yeah we have a it's simple
they like fried chicken make it's fried
chicken and keep it by side of the bed
right right so that's a good idea now
what about a humor in the bedroom is
humor I mean people are always saying
humor is an important part of marriage
you think it's something that you should
bring into the bedroom situation now
it's all seriousness not serious
business up in there no ain't no jokes
going down like we got it we got a turn
we we got a charter then no clown shoes
yeah no clown shoes and left that work
are you all right if that works for you
if you need the clown shoes in the nose
she does it pal it works for you boy
what works for me as a wife that's just
willing
not asleep yeah happy Valentine's Day
Andy Conan a so so so you're saying no
but you're very serious when it comes to
your sensual time together um like very
white he's really lose game you have a
tournament I'd say you have to like AM
radio FM radio AM is we're telling jokes
we're having fun but when we turn it to
FM everything gets low yeah we don't
start getting you know what soon as I
start talking like this she knows to
start turning off things right and
getting everything correct right it's
about to get real serious I like it yeah
you're real critical somebody might get
hurt
no I'm fulfilled that's very cool and
this is as low as my voice goes right
now I like serious hear things you're
gonna get serious and someone's gonna
get hurt
and you have sex with that voice not
with the you yeah oh god it's a turn-on
I like when guys make me laugh you make
me laugh
that's not in front of iced tea here